les petites cuillères les lutins et
aristarque de samos
n'avez vous jamais perdu des affaires et
parfois de manière extraordinaire et
dans toutes les maisons tourne toujours
les mêmes questions
où sont passés les petites cuillères
pourquoi ma chaussette at elle perdu sa
paire pour résoudre ce mystère
je suis allé voir les plus grands
experts ceux ci sont formels les petites
cuillères part dans les poubelles
mais concernant les chaussettes et leur
disparition je n'entend point de leurs
explications
et pour tout vous dire même pour les
cuillères à leur raisonnement je n'y
crois guère car moi j'y suis allé sur
les décharges publiques et je n'y ai
point vue de ces objets ou blick
alors j'ai tourné la question dans tous
les sens jusqu'à ce que je comprenne que
des lutins cela prouve l existence je
devine se lever vos sourcils sceptiques
me trouvant mon raisonnement pas très
logique et je sens bien que vous n'êtes
pas prêt à me croire mais pourquoi ne
voulez-vous pas changé votre façon de
voir
car la cuillère est très utile aux
lutins à leur sert d'outil pour creuser
des chemins et c'est la petite cuillère
uniquement c'est elle qui leur sert
d'instrument
car à leur taille elle est adaptée c'est
pour ça qu'elle seule disparaît s'il y
avait une autre bonne raison les grande
cuillère disparaîtrait aussi de la
maison de même pour les fourchettes les
couteaux alors qu'il reste bien sagement
près des fourneaux en plus avec les
lutins je résous l'autre mystère celui
des chaussettes qui n'ont plus leur père
en effet les lutins ont besoin de bonnet
et pour cela nos chaussettes ont adopté
et comme ils n'ont qu'une seule tête
eh bien ils ne prennent qu'une seule
chaussettes
oui j'entends bien vos sourire
sarcastique pourtant j'ai le défi ce
soir de vous partager ma conviction car
je suis persuadé que les lutins existe
et mon ambition c'est de faire que dans
les quinze minutes qui viennent pendant
ne serait ce le temps d'un instant vous
puissiez partager avec moi cette
certitude il ya plein de preuve de
l'existence des lutins il ya tous ces
objets de notre quotidien qui
disparaissent les petites cuillères et
elles partent pas dans les poubelles
parce que sinon ça fait longtemps qu'on
aurait demi des systèmes de recyclage
dans les centres de tri les chaussettes
aussi dans toutes les maisons il ya des
chaussettes dépareillées dans les
maisons de famille nombreuse il ya des
sacs entiers de chaussettes dépareillées
wasquehal passe ses chaussettes
certains pensent qu'elle parte dans les
machines à laver je crois pas parce que
dans les machines à laver si vous en
avez démonter une fois il ya un filtre
de vidange le moindre bout de tissu
bloque la machine à laver et si les
chaussettes partait le long des tambours
de machine à laver les fabricants
auraient réglé le problème depuis
longtemps et puis que dire découverte de
taux power que dire de ces clés qu'on a
cherché toute la journée qu'on a fini
par retrouver ranger là on a l'habitude
de les déposer
et puis il n'avez vous jamais chercher
un papier un objet toute la journée
voire même plusieurs journées pour le
retrouver dans un endroit complètement
improbable il vous dira mais comment est
ce qu'il a fait pour atterrir à la je
pourrais vous donner beaucoup d'exemples
comme ça de nos objets qui disparaissent
au quotidien et puis aussi autre chose
qui me prouve que les lutins existe
imaginons que je me rallie à ce que vous
pensez que les lutins n'existe pas qui
n'ont jamais existé
mais alors comment se fait-il j'ai pas
mal voyagé j'ai eu la chance d'habiter
sur quatre continents
comment se fait-il que dans ces cas là
tous les peuples tous les pays aient
inventé la notion de lutins s'il
n'existait pas peut-être que certains
l'aurait fait venir est plein de peuples
qui n'aurait jamais pensé aux lutins
alors on les appelle lutins trop le
nomme jean farfadets elf que sais-je
d'autres chaque pays chaque
peuple a inventé des lutins des
évidences comme ça sur l'existence des
lutins j'en ai beaucoup
je pourrais continuer mais je sais que
ça va être difficile de vous convaincre
et c'est normal on est au labo d'orléans
on est dans un incubateur numérique
on est dans le cas d'une conférence ted
j'ai donc en face de moi un public formé
cultivé qui a beaucoup de certitudes et
accable souvent beaucoup de mal à
remettre en cause ses certitudes alors
j'aurais pu choisir un défi peut-être
plus facile
choisir de m'adresser à de jeunes
enfants ou si j'avais la baguette
magique de laurence j'aurais pu nous
transporter dans une autre période à
orléans par exemple au moyen âge
sauf que si je commence à vous parler
d'enfance de moyen-âge vous allez avoir
du mal à me suivre parce que l'enfant
c'est la naïveté c'est la crédulité le
moyen-âge c'est l'obscurantisme
au moyen-age on croyait que la terre
était plate au moyen âge on croyait que
le soleil tournait autour n'da de la
terre
au moyen-age on pensait que l'univers
avait été créé pour l'homme ce qu'on
appelle l'anthropocentrisme alors tout
ça aujourd'hui on sait que c'est pas
vrai même moi qui crois que les lutins
existe je sais que la terre est ronde
comme vous tous enfin un rationnement
est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un dans la salle
qui penserait que la terre est plate
personne est-ce qu'on aurait patrick
baudry jean louis chrétien claudie
haigneré ou un des ciseaux de
spationautes
dans la serre hélas non donc j'aimerais
quand même qu'on réfléchisse à quelque
chose on a tous la certitude absolue que
la terre est ronde et personne ne l'a
expérimenté par lui-même personne
personne expérimentée que les lutins
existé ou existent et paella ya que moi
qui crois personne expérimentée que la
terre était ronde ou pas mais là par
contre on est tous d'accord
comment ça se fait en fait on en crée
beaucoup de certitudes en nous sans les
vérifier
il ya trois grands chemins pour le faire
premier des chemins c'est papa m'a dit
ou s'écrit sur internet
c'est l'autorité qu'on donne à quelqu'un
qui fait que quoi qu'ils disent quoi
qu'il écrive quoi qu'ils pensent
on prendra pour argent comptant ce qu'il
nous dira sans le vérifier
celui qu'on appelle l'expert souvent les
parents nourriciers souvent les premiers
formateurs les premiers éducateurs mais
ça peut être aussi une personne morale
un groupe en qui on donne toute
confiance la deuxième raison c'est que
on s'est tous construits depuis qu'on
est enfant une compréhension raisonnée
du monde pour pouvoir agir dedans
pouvoir pouvoir inter interagir sens
monde et donc tout ce qui vient
corroborer cette construction du monde
on le valide sans trop de vérifier et
tout ce qui ne vient pas le valider on
leur jette croire que les luttes existe
et pour vous quelque chose de
profondément déraisonnable donc n'être
pas près de me croire puis la troisième
chose c'est qu'on a besoin de sens alors
souvent c'est dans un premier temps une
croyance qui devient parfois rapidement
une certitude on a besoin de comprendre
les choses croire au moyen-âge que la
terre avait été créé pour l'homme c'est
quand même pour nos existences à nous
quelque chose de beaucoup plus
valorisant que de penser qu'on est juste
un 7 milliardième sur une petite planète
quel perdu dans l'univers on en crée
beaucoup de choses en nous sans les
vérifier
on a nos obscurantisme aujourd'hui aussi
alors ne regardons pas trop le moyen-âge
avec condescendance
parce que quand j'entends que
d'entraînement notre amérique si moderne
il y a des gens qui sont créationnistes
c'est ceux qui croient que le monde a
été vraiment créé en cette fois en sept
jours en cette fois 24 heures que des
gens ne croient pas en septembre ne
crois pas qu'on est allé sur la lune
vont nier les chambres à gaz où quand je
vois un certain nombre de fans fanatisme
je me dis que nos obscurantisme
d'aujourd'hui n'ont pas forcément grand
chose à envier à celui du moyen âge une
fois qu'on sait on à accepter l'idée
qu'on a on crée beaucoup d'idées en nous
et de certitudes sans les vérifier
il ya tout de suite une autre question
qui vient en miroir est ce qu'au moins
ce que l'on vérifie ce que l'on
expérimente on peut en faire une
certitude
hélas non on connaît les illusions
d'optique
on connaît un certain nombre de
phénomènes aux cons c'est faux et compte
que nos sens sont trompés par ces
phénomènes là il ya quelque chose qu'on
n'ose pas trop ça vous est quelque chose
sur lequel on s'appuie tous les jours
quelque chose sur lequel on se tient
debout quelque chose qui compte dans
notre vie tout le temps sur lequel on ne
prend pas forcément le temps de regarder
et écouter ce que les savants nous
disent la matière les plus grands
savants enfin tout cas une partie
pensent que la matière n'existe pas
c'est juste une ondée une énergie en
tout cas avec certitude
on sait que c'est 99.999 9% de vide et
je peux l'expliquer assez facilement
petit souvenir de première ou de
terminale la matière elle est composée
d'atomes jeu les atouts et les atomes
s'associe aux molécules un atom il ya un
noyau un électron qui tourne autour
et quand la molécule se forme c'est pas
les noyaux qui fusionne ensemble c'est
les électrons qui tournent ensemble et
qu'ils formaient un espèce de 8
le noyau restant dans le centre de
chaque 8 généralement on représente ça
avec comme une petite terre avec un
satellite au tour sauf qu'en fait on
fait une erreur d'échelle et pour bien
comprendre je vais ramener un atom le
plus simple celui d'hydrogène à notre
taille si je ramène le noyaux
d'hydrogène à la taille d'un petit pois
et que je le pose là au milieu de ce x
si je veux poser l'électron le plus
proche possible de lui sachant kien
polarité opposés et que comme deux
aimants ils s'opposent pour le poser au
plus proche je vais pas le poser sur le
bord ni du x ni de l'estrade il va
falloir que j'aille le poser à 100
mètres de ce noyau
ça veut dire que ramener à notre échelle
entre les deux il ya 100 mètres de vide
imaginez en plan imaginez on en volume
avec certitude la matière c'est 99,9 9 9
9 % du vide
puis après c'est ce noyau qui est fait
de protons et de neutrons cet électron
de quoi sont ils faits il faudrait que
je vous parle de quark de bezons de
fermions vous parle de particules sans
masse c'est d'ailleurs quelque chose
j'ai beaucoup de mal à comprendre plus
grands scientifiques parlent autant de
particules sont minces terre qui est une
particule qui existe qui n'a pas de
masque a pas de matière et vous préférez
croire écouter ces gens là que de penser
avec les lutins existe vous avez de la
chance parce que moi j'ai beaucoup de
mal
pourquoi est ce que je vous raconte tout
ça ce soir d'abord parce que il n'ya
peut-être pas beaucoup de certitudes
peut-être qu'il y en aurait qu'une celle
qu'on va mourir
enfin quand je regarde comment je me
comporte tous les jours je me dis que
c'est pas une certitude qui visiblement
ggg à l'esprit tout le temps et puis
même ça ça semble plus très certain dans
le cadre du transhumanisme qui est tous
ces mouvements qu'il ya autour de
l'intelligence artificielle sur toutes
les parties aussi du artificielle qu'on
met dans le dans le corps il ya un des
plus grands scientifiques de la silicon
valley qui dit qu'à partir de 2000 45
on pourra être immortel donc même mourir
ne semble plus être une certitude
l'objet des conférences ted c'est de
transformer le monde au travers des
idées qu'on peut avoir six ont commencé
par transformer notre regard qu'on a sur
le monde se regarde qu'on a il est fait
de toutes nos certitudes
certaines sont justes d'autres on les a
ancré peut-être un peu trop rapidement
sans les vérifier
il faut qu'on se questionne là dessus
parce que c'est possible de se
questionner
c'est possible de vérifier un certain
nombre de choses on n'aura pas pour la
plupart d'entre nous la chance de partir
dans l'espace et de vérifier par
nous-mêmes que la terre est ronde
par contre dans les lieux au centrisme
il ya aussi le fait que la terne tourne
sur elle même et ça c'est possible de le
vérifier il suffit d'aller au panthéon
au musée des arts et métiers et de faire
l'expérience du pendule de foucault qui
prouve que la terre tourne
et puis à toute période ait eu
possibilité de s'interroger de regarder
les choses même au moyen âge période de
ces obscures au moyen-âge étaient connus
aristarque de samos arqués aristarque de
samos
un grec du 3e siècle avant jésus-christ
qui a décrit exactement l'héliocentrisme
c'est à dire le soleil au milieu c'est à
dire que depuis trois siècles avant
jésus-christ on avait la connaissance de
la cosmologie et en tout cas de comment
les planètes fonctionner et tournait
autour du soleil
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a pas écouté
aristarque de samos durant le moyen-âge
alors qu'on le connaissait pour sa
théorie bizarre du monde ayant traité
d'alger m
et bien parce qu aristarque de samos il
arrive un siècle après aristote et
aristote c'est la grande sommités de
toute l'antiquité et de tout le moyen
âge
il a une philosophie globale sur tout
donc on n'allait pas remettre aristote
en cause uniquement parce qu'il s'était
trompé sur la conception du monde
ce qu'ils pensaient que la terre était
le centre de tout puis la deuxième chose
au moyen-âge dans la construction
raisonnée des choses on voyait le soleil
tourner dans le ciel
eh ben on pensait que c'était le soleil
qui tournait et ça me semble très
logique
puis la terre moi je les ai jamais vus
ronde je les ai vus plate vallonné les
anciens savaient même que la courbure de
l'horizon de la mer comme ils pensaient
que la terre était plate il a bien
analysé que la courbure de l'horizon de
la mer c'est un effet d'optique ses 1ers
en aucun cas la courbure de la terre
et puis évidemment croire que le monde
avait été créé pour nous les hommes pour
moi blaise va forcément ça donne un
meilleur sens à la vie que de penser
autre chose
interrogeons nous sur nos certitudes
quelles sont nos obscurantisme sur le
monde extérieur sur le monde intérieur
doute on est ce que nous experts étaient
bien des experts etait-il externes tout
interrogez vous doutez de tous à
commencer par ce que je viens de vous
raconter depuis 15 minutes
sauf peut-être sur une chose parce que
là dessus juin experts les lutins il
existe bien